la première centrale géothermique au
canada les énergies renouvelables
progressent mais on est encore loin de
pouvoir se passer des énergies fossiles
toutefois une alliance inattendue entre
ces deux mondes pourrait changer la
donne
[Musique]
ce sont les mêmes travailleurs et ceux
du pétrole
les mêmes outils de forage la même
science
ils sont l'industrie pétrolière on ne
saurait même pas de cette ressource
existe
mais ici ce qu'on cherche à plus de
trois kilomètres et demi sous terre
c'est de l'eau
de l'eau tellement chaude qu'on peut
s'en servir pour produire l'électricité
c'est incroyable c'est chouette avec le
projet dit le canada devrait bientôt
avoir sa toute première centrale
alimentée par la géothermie
on va produire de l'électricité très
bientôt
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le sud de la
saskatchewan
la géologue colston marcia a grandi ici
au milieu des champs et du puits de
pétrole
[Musique]
et c'est ici qu'elle prépare révolution
verte dans le domaine énergétique
j'ai passé toute ma carrière à
développer de nouvelles ressources
ce qui est unique avec la géothermie
c'est que tant que le centre de la terre
sera chaud on aura une source d'énergie
verte inépuisable une fois installé ça
fonctionne jour pourtant dans son coin
de pays
il n'y a aucun volcan à l'horizon son
trésor se cache loin sous terre dans des
roches vieille d'un demi milliard
d'années c'est de l'eau très salée et
surtout très chaude 125 degrés celsius
[Musique]
pour mieux nous l'a montré l'équipe de
10 a fait appel à un drone équipé d'une
caméra un peu particulière ça alors
regarde la différence de température
entre ça et ça
grâce à sa vision infrarouge on peut
voir directement la chaleur et il
faisait chaud cette journée là l'air
était à 38 degrés et le sol encore plus
chaud les humains en comparaison avait
l'air froid on voit très bien l'eau qui
est pompée dans un puits et entreposés
dans des réservoirs
salaire chose n'indique 92 19 degrés sur
ce réservoir
c'est incroyable pour moi de voir ça on
a beau savoir qu'il ya d'eau chaude dans
les réservoirs de la visualiser comme ça
c'est génial pour nous vîmes en soit la
géothermie n'est pas nouvelle mais au
canada
on ne s'en est jamais encore servi pour
produire de l'électricité
et pour ça il faut beaucoup d'eau chaude
[Musique]
la géothermie utilise d'énormes
quantités de liquide
on va utiliser l'équivalent de tous ces
réservoirs derrière en une heure
seulement énormément d'eau à déplacer au
quotidien
pour tromper de tels volumes d'eau il
faut aussi des roches bien particulière
qui permettent à l'autre circuler
karlsson marcia avait commencé ses
recherches ici
ces archives contiennent des
échantillons de tout ce qui a été foré
en saskatchewan
que ce soit pour trouver de l'or des
diamants de l'uranium
la potasse ou bien sûr du pétrole mais
ce qu'elle cherche elle c'est avant tout
d'être ou sow ce qu'on a ici c'est une
roche sédimentaire assez poreuse et les
porcs sont reliés entre eux ça permet à
l'autre se déplacer dans la roche
l'autre critère c'est la température en
profondeur une donnée à laquelle elle a
eu accès un peu par hasard quand on fait
un forage
on récolte plusieurs informations dans
le cas de température en fait ça sert
surtout à calibrer les autres
instruments de mesure sauf que pour nous
c'était la donnée centrale
[Musique]
qu'il s'agisse de température ou de
porosité toutes les informations
pointaient vers sa région natale le long
de la frontière américaine
s'il existe une zone idéale parmi les
couches de sédiments
il y en a une qui contient de l'eau à la
bonne température et où la roche est
assez perméable pour pomper avec le baby
qu'il nous faut c'est ce qui explique le
design retenu pour la première centrale
[Musique]
le prochain forage descendra à 3,5 km et
une fois dans la zone idéale le fuit
continuera à l'horizontale sur deux
autres kilomètres puis jumeaux partira
dans l'autre direction
et plus au nord s'ajouteront deux autres
paires depuis l'eau chaude pompe est
amené un échangeur de chaleur on extrait
une partie de son énergie et on la
transfère un deuxième lui d'
probablement du brutal qui va facile de
liquide à gaz
c'est ce gaz qui fait tourner la turbine
qui produit l'électricité
il sera ensuite condensé et vais
utiliser ça s'appelle un cycle binaire
parce qu'ils aiment boucle des liquides
qui transfère la chaleur et une look
dauchot donc on réinjecte un peu plus
froid cet os à 65 degrés celsius est
réinjecté entre les puits de pompage en
père colin à travers des roches
sédimentaires elles se réchauffent peu à
peu la question c'est de savoir quelle
distance laissé entre les différents
points
c'est justement l'objectif des tests
menés lors de notre passage pendant des
semaines aux pompes de l'eau on y ajoute
traceur chimiques et on l'a réinjecte
750 mètres plus loin on peut ainsi
calculer le temps qu'il lui faut pour se
déplacer dans la roche avant d'être
écarté à nouveau la première centrale
doit produire 20 mégawatts d'électricité
de quoi alimenter 20 mille maisons
l'équipe 2 des iep prépare déjà le
terrain pour une deuxième centrale qui
produira un autre 20 mégawatts
le premier puits est encore plus profond
trois mille sept cent trente mètres un
record au canada le test avec cette fois
le gaz sous pression qu'on injecte tout
au fond du puits
et après quelques heures d'attentes le
gaz remontent
l'eau commence à couler
l'information clé c'est évidemment la
température mais on analyse aussi la
composition chimique de l'eau en
particulier les celles qui pourraient
s'accumuler dans les réservoirs ou la
tuyauterie
on s'intéresse aussi aux bactéries qui
pourraient proliférer et fer rouillé les
tuyaux ou créer des bouchons
on ne veut pas avoir des surprises
notre ressource pourrait être un peu
meilleur ou un peu moins bonne mieux
vaut le savoir tout
d'après ce qu'on sait ça devrait être
assez similaires dans toute la région
nous on est assez loin du premier site
alors on veut vérifier nos hypothèses et
voir s'il ya des changements subtils
d'un endroit à l'autre
les centrales géothermiques ne te lis
jamais toute l'énergie contenue dans
l'eau
ailleurs dans le monde on utilise l'eau
encore chaude pour réchauffer des
piscines des bassins d'aquaculture et
sert ou même des trottoirs en hiver
quand je donne ma sia pense que la
géothermie peut aider sa région à
diversifier son économie et à prendre le
virage vert ça
tourner le dos aux travailleurs du
pétrole c'est une situation unique
on peut miser sur une expertise de
classe mondiale pour développer cette
ressource dans tout le canada
il n'y a pas un endroit aussi bien
équipée pour forer deux puits aussi
élaborer les travailleurs du pétrole
vont pouvoir appliquer directement leurs
compétences un projet d'énergie
renouvelable et ça c'est vraiment une
première
[Musique]